this is not a country number one it's a
country it is not governed by Christian
rules how much are you getting paid what
are you getting paid for hating on
Muslims hate on Muslims how much do you
get
our planet majority of them very happy
[Music]
we are going
[Music]
[Applause]
no one is threatening you no one is
saying anything you just hate her who
likes to paint Muslims as barbarians and
terrorists you are being paid for hating
all Muslims
let's talk them welcome listening
I'm listening because I'm and I know
that's a carry on yes that is a
religious now it is very disrespectful
to protest this woman she knows nothing
when hates she knows nothing but hate
she always hates all Muslims she doesn't
want to see any positivity in Muslims
even a peaceful crowd is a mob to her
these people these people to get paid
for hating on Muslims this is a famous
islamaphobe who peddles hate around
around the world
we're dropping so what's your problem
with Muslims hello okay
this is going to be a conversation it's
really disrespectful that you all
gathered here for no religion that's
your opinion we the Muslims respect
every human on the planet and so my
opinion is we wouldn't do something like
this on E
you see one you are perfectly free to do
that no problem - your opinion is anyone
disrespecting Hindus there she's lying
that's fine that's your opinion no it's
the reason why I call you a liar because
you've lied repeatedly on social media
against Muslim you active you defaced
the Indian embassy building I went with
any of you do that Muslims or these
individuals thank you thank you yes we
listening you said you you use the word
you when you said you okay last time you
protested the embassy was two-faced and
we can we condemn that
do we condemn that yes women we condemn
that okay Katie today today yes can you
guarantee me that today
the Indian Embassy will not be deface
can we guarantee that please how who are
you asking all these individuals okay
then then in that case then in that case
let me respond to you you should go to
the leadership head and talk to them
okay okay okay okay
they would be happy to talk to you
reiji's okay let me respond now they
would be happy to talk to you if they
knew you as an impartial sympathizer or
the Kashmiri people but what they do
know about Katie Hopkins this one what
they know I'm very careful what they do
know about you is that you are an
established well-paid islamaphobe who
peddles hate
hate against innocent innocent Muslims
around the world because of you there
are Muslim women being attacked around
the world around the world you are
responsible for all these against Muslim
women in the West this is why this is
why we call right now let me see some if
there is a crowd of a thousand people in
the thousand people crowd in the in that
crowd if there are five nutters who end
up doing things against against the
wishes of a thousand people how can we
guarantee just like white super loses
okay I'm not sure save Inori wait okay
can you guarantee
can you guarantee Katie can you
guarantee that no white racist super
assist people who are inspired by you
directly I'm not going to walk into
mosques and gun down
listen listen can you okay can you
guarantee they are inspired by your
articles can I read your feet can you
I'm not touching your money points I can
point it to you as much as I'll point
again I'll point again come talk to me
I'm standing okay but you chose you
[Music]
now now now now I don't know you chose
to come in
you chose and we're talking no one is
threatening no one is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm trying to speak to it I'm I'm trying
to speak
[Music]
don't stop doing that and give me the
bad news oh stop doing that
[Music]
so we just had a chat with Katie Hopkins
famous Islamophobe Katie Hopkins who is
known for spreading hate against Muslims
actively if you read her articles if she
read her Twitter account you will see
how much hate she has against Muslims
and today she has come here to cause
trouble she wants to be attacked by some
nutter
so that she can go and become a hero
online so this is what she's trying to
do and we're not going to allow that to
happen we won't we don't want anyone any
crazy nutter to say anything to her so
they see
[Music]
so miss Hopkins miss Hawkins
keep moving otherwise
[Applause]
we're gonna continue with our
conversation a friendly friendly
conversation we're gonna ask miss
Hopkins
why does she tell us so much hate
against Muslims who who is paying her so
we will question miss Hopkins as to who
is actually paying her so miss Hopkins
who is actually paying you for peddling
hate against muscle Knight who's paying
a post translationally that's fine no
problem she's on a world okay so am i
miss Hopkins who is actually paying you
for peddling hate against Muslims can I
know we want to know we're interested
because you lie about Muslims a lot you
lie you lie about our demographics you
lie about what we do socially you lie
about Muslims at large and you have
caused a lot of attacks against Muslim
women people white Superman system
terrorists are inspired by you they they
read your articles doesn't read your
article thanks for him they read your
articles and they do not attack against
Muslims right so know why you I'm not
touching on freaking - I get it okay
it's no problem miss miss Hopkins can
you can you respond to my question I'm a
journalist by the way
okay okay I don't have a media sponsor
I'm a social media this one okay no
problem
so you can see the police is actually
escorting this Islamophobe away from the
crowd for the right reasons I admire
that in police I really appreciate that
but they are not allowing it did not and
she's actually running away as you can
see she doesn't want to talk to someone
who can respond to her points someone
who is informed enough to respond to her
points thank you for protecting us I
just want to have a conversation Tom in
a place to have the conversation is
right yes yeah and they say oh why she
would say this one is a notorious
Islamic fault she shouldn't be here in
the first place in this crowd because
she knows there are people who recognize
her she wants to cause the commotion she
really wants to water down the okay a
legitimate protest against oppression
and that's why yeah thank you okay thank
you I really appreciate that so ladies
and gentlemen you just saw what happened
here this woman who's in who's unknown
islamaphobe she has turned up she has
enough audacity having pedaled so much
hate against Muslim women Muslim people
in general
she has come come to this rally and she
expects Muslims to love her she expects
Muslims to receive her as an impartial
observer no we asked her questions we
protected her against any threats or
anything like that because there are not
just it is very possible there are some
crazy people one or two or three crazy
people in the crowd who might want to to
say something or anything like that and
this is why some people like Katie
Hopkins turn up to places like this so
that they can use this against Muslims
look I got attacked by Muslims
I got threatened by Muslims I was
verbally abused by Muslims this is what
they want to do they want to use all
these things against the Muslims we
demonstrated today that we want to talk
to people like
we want to show them what the reality is
these people these Islamophobes
especially people like her that peddle a
lot of hate against Muslims on social
media with impunity and amazingly the
government is not doing anything against
them people like her and Tommy Robinson
they're running around spreading hate
against Muslims causing attacks against
vulnerable Muslim women so this was one
of the ways we talk to these people
we confront them we challenge the views
in a decent fashion of course it was a
crowd it was a very charged situation we
had to shout at times because we
couldn't be heard but hopefully it has
been demonstrated today that we are not
scared of talking to people like this we
will challenge them wherever we find
them and we will ask them questions and
we will challenge their views and we
will successfully rebut refute their
wheels
thank you for watching sorry